je ne suis dupe de rien mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs je suis dupe de
rien
et sans préambule car votre temps est
précieux je vais entrer donc dans le vif
du sujet en toute transparence
je vais parler en toute transparence
pour vous donner les éléments afin que
vous puissiez vous approcher de la
vérité au plus près
mais je vais parler en toute
transparence pour dire aussi des choses
qui me plaisent que j'ai entendu que
j'ai écouté et que je ne peux laisser
passer
je vais probablement j'espère pas je
vais probablement alimenter la polémique
à travers à travers ce que je vais vous
dire
j'aurais préféré franchement ne pas
m'exprimer ainsi mais malheureusement
comme souvent dans ce type d'affaires
l'un des sens l'emporte sur la raison
et sur la retenue
je le dis mesdames et messieurs devant
vous tous serment
et devant l'opinion publique
non non
et non le sujet qui intéresse votre
commission d'enquête n'est pas
l'expression de la République des
copains pour reprendre le propos
scandaleux car insultant et diffamatoire
utilisé par l'un de vos collègues
sur une chaîne de télévision en
l'occurrence Public Sénat
je parle de vous monsieur le sénateur
Daniel broyier il n'y a pas eu de
copinage dans cette affaire et je vous
prie Monsieur le Président de rappeler à
vos collègues la décence qui exige cette
affaire ne serait-ce pour la mémoire de
la victime que vous avez cité
le premier copinage qui devrait
d'ailleurs être dénoncé c'est celui qui
dit votre courant politique celui des
écologistes
alislamisme et ceux dans plusieurs
villes de France
voilà l'intitulé d'une vraie commission
d'enquête permettez-moi l'expression qui
aurait de la gueule si j'ose dire
je passe ce premier point parce qu'il
fallait l'expérience
ainsi je ne puis tolérer et je le dis
calmement
et je pense qu'aucun démocrate ne peut
le tolérer que l'on puisse lorsqu'on est
sénateur
élu parce que la chose a concerné aussi
l'autre chambre certains députés
et lorsqu'on est de surcroît membre
d'une commission d'enquête tenir dans la
presse des propos accusatoires avant
même la fin des travaux de cette même
commission d'enquête je peux vous dire
donc mon indignation car ce type de
procédé qui se substitue à la justice au
nord ni son auteur ni l'exercice
démocratique je ne fais aucun amalgame
parce que je sais que la majorité des
sénateurs et des parlementaires ont eu
une attitude de dignité je ferme donc
cette première parenthèse
depuis plus de deux mois
j'assiste impuissant à ce piétinement
d'une sacro-sainte valeurs la
présomption d'innocence
alors que nous sommes aujourd'hui d'un
point de vue pénal au stade de
l'ouverture d'une information judiciaire
certains juges utiles dirigés déjà des
bûchers
je vous rappelle que seul la justice
accuse vous l'avez dit monsieur le
président
votre rôle ici vous le connaissez
parfaitement j'en suis conscient
et il ne consiste donc pas à accuser il
sera
utile de le rappeler à chacune des
étapes
avant de répondre à vos questions
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs
avant de livrer ma vérité en toute
transparence
je souhaiterais quand même remettre les
enjeux au centre du village si j'ose
dire sans me dérober et sont éviter
aucune question
je suis sous serment je l'ai rappelé et
vous le savez
il y a eu sans doute sans doute des
erreurs partagées dans cette affaire
et je vous ferai pas au fur et à mesure
des griefs que j'ai moi-même contre les
uns et les autres les politiques
l'administration
mais contrairement à d'autres je ne suis
pas venu ici pour défendre une carrière
je ne suis pas venu ici
pour faire de la communication
je ne suis pas venu ici pour me
justifier comme ce justifierait un
coupable parce que je ne suis coupable
de rien d'un point de vue pénal je le
répète
le fond est le plus grave à mes yeux
c'est ce que je vais vous dire
aujourd'hui
et j'ai des grilles contre elle
l'on s'attaque à une ministre
de la République
en vérité on s'attaque un gouvernement
au mépris de la vérité parfois
non je le dis
Marlène Schiappa n'est pas mon ami elle
n'a pas été hier et elle le sera encore
moins demain
mais non Marlène Schiappa
n'écoutable ni de détournement d'argent
ni d'un quelconque copinage je le
précise
[Musique]